storytelling is my religion
it's so it's nothing i will ever
if there are gods of storytelling i'm
never going to
go against the gods of storytelling so
what mistakes do writers make when
writing characters i don't know if they
make mistakes writing characters um well
maybe they do
um
it's just find ways to make them
three-dimensional
and there's always ways and i think
that's when i think in the end your
character just needs
we need to know what the character's
goal is and then just
make it harder for him that's that's
about it um
so for the most part it's uh
yeah it's i i think i think i do find
some people are you know that then this
is one that comes oh no this is based on
a true story and no this is a real
person and it's just like
okay but
get back to the get back to the page
stop doing the verbatim on you know but
i also think that's a technique that
technique that's a very great word for
it it's a way for people to avoid
actually writing it's a way for them to
avoid actually sinking into the conflict
of
the possibilities of that character so
they can just say oh no this really
happened and it's just like
you just don't want to go there
that's okay
don't be a writer
it's not a it's it's not a
hugely paying gig unless it is sometimes
it's it's mostly sad
you know it's it only looks pretty in
movies so
why wouldn't where would they not want
to go
i mean i find this i find this a lot and
i find this in the majority of
you know maybe 70 percent of the
students that take my classes they they
don't want to they it's like when we
were talking about the um
the evilness and the darkness i i don't
think they want to go into the darkness
of their characters because they're too
scared to show the darkness of
themselves
and that's when we're gonna completely
that's that's just when the
the the cat the sand castle of the story
you're creating just won't work it's
um
you need to know the imperfections
that's that's the
it's the fun part you know
right so they make this character
too perfect or or it's too flat
yeah too flat and just it doesn't yeah
it's just it's reading like they're
avoiding
and
usually i'll ask them what they're
avoiding and
oh no no this really happened and
there's people there's a lot of
students who just don't want notes
and you just kind of find them and go
all right well you're not getting notes
then it's just like oh you know what
my standard is um
oh well thanks for sending this in and
you know just sprinkle more conflict
if a student's getting that note from me
that means that i realize they're not
taking any notes and they just want a
participation grade so
so if i let's suppose i turn something
in and and you
you give me a first pass of first round
of notes
and then you see that i don't integrate
or i don't change anything does that
mean i'm not receptive no it's um
it usually uh
you know i don't mind i don't mind if a
student's confused i don't mind if a
student is is even offended and like
whoa wait a second but the the cut then
the conversation let's have the
conversation and
and it doesn't mean that they need to
become take every note and become great
you know in the next scenes but but you
could start to tell
you know after a few workshops where
you're just like it's just it just
happens or the the practice is happening
it's just like oh you're hitting it
you're hitting it you're hitting that
conflict you're you're hitting this i'm
seeing what you're doing here and here
and here
um
you can just you could tell when
someone's avoiding
truth almost and when someone just uh
and that and that's what that's the one
thing that i really kind of preach
to every writing class that i teach is
write your truth
i can give you an outline
with 90 i can give you 90 story beats
with the character with the all the plot
and everything i can give it to every
one of you
and tell you to go write it and you're
all going to come back with completely
different
um
screenplays
because you're gonna come with exactly
who you are
how you grew up your tragedies your
victories
you know
you you have the fingerprint and that's
the beauty of
being a writer it's like
people get so stuck on ideas oh that's a
good idea it's like it doesn't the idea
doesn't matter it's your fingerprint on
how
the story how you're telling the story
because every story's been told you know
they may pretend like oh we got this new
thing that we did it like this and it's
just like
all right but in the end it's still a
heist movie or in the end it's still a
love story uh that you know you found a
little different angle on but they're
the core of it the core that we care
about
is still in there so that then that will
that'll never go away and
that's when i
i even say hey if you're lucky enough to
get on an adam sandler movie and you
know adam sandler writes goofy movies
but
if you're lucky enough to get a project
on that put your truth in there big go
ahead and be goofy but
put an element of your truth in there
and that will make you stand above and
they'll be like then when they read it
they'll be like you know what i don't
know why i like this but i like it and
that's when we're putting our own truth
into the work and we don't have to
totally spell it out
but that's when people go i connect to
this and i don't know exactly why or how
but usually that means the writer the
writer has brought in just utter truth
and honesty and storytelling
do you find people are sometimes scared
because you're so honest
it intimidates them because then that
means they have to meet you at that
level
probably i should probably uh
be less intimidating
well not intentionally but but i mean
this is who you are and you want to yeah
and i don't expect i mean i
i don't expect everyone to
have to you know deal with uh the my
demons the way i deal with them um
yeah there's it's um
you know i i can tell when there's
uh avoidance in a sci-fi
you know it's
the alien isn't looking at themselves
like yeah yeah the alien looks at
himself in the mirror and says i'm
gorgeous and green
yeah um
there's there's just there's
it's just interesting because i think
and i didn't even realize this but i've
read so much work that i can
really tell fast
um
if if they uh
if they're into it
and if they
it and if they had a stake in writing it
there's this with and i don't know
exactly what it is and i don't know how
to explain it
but i could read five pages of something
and realize if um
if they're invested and this is
important or if this is an exercise and
they're trying to and they're just
trying to sell something
which could just be selling the teacher
for a good grade or
yeah yeah yeah okay or even scripts that
are given to me going hey can you
you know can you do a read through on
this and give and give me uh some pages
of coverage and i'm like yeah and i'll
be like sometimes i've given back
scripts after 10 pages and i'll be like
you didn't do the work yet
um so
it's just you know and then they're
i there's something i have with um with
writing is i kind of can't
i have a problem
sugarcoating it sometimes but but but
storytelling is my religion
it's so it's nothing i will ever
if there are gods of storytelling i'm
never going to
go against the gods of storytelling so
um i hate it when someone asks me oh did
you like my book and i'm just like
you know
i would never ask that of anybody i
don't even expect anyone to read
anything i you know but if someone says
that
um
i kind of have to either tell them the
truth or avoid it in some way
and sometimes i might might say
you know it was great to see you on that
publisher or i really liked that you got
to work with that editor and all they
hear is great and like they don't hear
that i didn't say anything about the
book but i have to kind of
i can't say a book's greater a
screenplay is great
if i feel on my bones it's not
and i might be a jerk because of that i
don't know
well also too sometimes if you're going
on a junket or press junket you don't
always have time to do i mean you
sometimes get this stuff last minute so
you don't always have time to read
something or even get a screener
but but
you know i mean
sometimes it's not just the work it's
also the person that did the work and
that's fascinating too
oh exactly oh i totally agree i agree
beyond belief there's i mean
that that
the person behind the work intrigues me
i think i'm talking about my friends
when my friends come up to me and we'll
ask that and that throws me off but like
when i interview like every once every
like 15 to 20 people will ask
and um
that's uh
i kind of have to i have to rest i have
to re-steer it because i because when i
do interviews i'm there to have the
conversation with the person i'm not
there to
uh if we discuss storytelling great if
you know but i'd rather um
i'd rather not go into the details of
the character of the book because that's
for other
you know that's for the other shows i
guess yeah or the question i love
how was it to work with so and so there
was such a big name
you know that's like one of the i hear
these journalists will ask that in
junkets and different things and
sometimes it's like well you're in a
sense insulting the person
but hey that's just my my thing is i
always ask were they not were they were
they nice to work with okay um and
it's really fun to hear because and then
you know i
if i was uh yeah i was on a
set and right before covid and
someone was telling me about one of my
favorite
stars and i was like how was he to work
with and they were like
he was nice above the line but below the
line he was not a good person to people
and i was like
that's that's you know i don't want to
hear that
yeah and plus you don't know what the
person's going through but i get it i
guess if you hear enough stories but
sometimes
you don't you know there's a few people
that i've heard were difficult and then
i've seen
someone come up and insist on a photo
and different things in a really rude
way held it really well and i was like
wow they they actually
you know so you sometimes you just never
know
you need to know the audience
that's telling you that if it's someone
that's been working in film for 20 years
and they're working on film after film
after tv show after tv show i'll take
i'll take notice when they you know but
everyone knows everyone has a bad day
sure sure i assume everyone has a bad
day so i never yeah if someone was like
oh i met someone on the street and he
was a jerk i just kind of look at him
and go i
yeah i don't care